must be grateful to to see this project
come to the light this is
this is pretty cool man i think even
watching the trailer
it brings back thoughts of being a kid
and just wanting to go to the moon like
wanting to be an astronaut like
you must have had that when you were
young too oh
i still have it i think about it all the
time it's uh
it captures my imagination in a way that
um i just recently i watched the crown
episode there was one the crown episode
this season where they talk about the
the moon landing and the effect it was
uh
it was having on the uh oh god what's
his name what's the queen's husband's
name
phillip oh my god oh my god uh
it's an it's a phenomenal episode i
think because it contextualized it it
just grasped like how powerful
that time was and how it is also
specifically i think
this sort of masculine quality of these
these these men going out to this
this new world he's like they're the
only people to go there and accomplish
this great task and
how it can sort of uh take over all our
whole imagination
yeah and these guys are the first like
the immense amount of pressure
on these guys like who can imagine it i
mean you're imagining it you got to step
into the shoes of john glenn
you must have really you must have ate
that all up
yeah i mean i loved it what i think i
came to understand which i found even
more
fascinating was that you know while
these guys and especially glenn he had
a deep sense of imagination and wonder
about what they were sort of on the
precipice of and what they were going to
do
you know for them they were also pilots
like this on a technical level they were
like
ready for this or they thought so you
know i think they each had their own
sort of mystical experience almost
although i don't think they qualify it
that way when they flew
um i think something like that happened
to each of them but in terms of the
dynamics of the thing of the logistics
of the flight
you know by the time they came they were
prepared to fly i mean
it's they had already basically gone
through the experience they had trained
so much and so hard for this
um to the point where you know alan
shepard who
was famously his flight was only about
15 minutes long
you know he was sort of disappointed i
think in all reports from the flight
because he had he had trained so long
and hard for this experience and
in the the video that played on his
training vessel was actually a better
view of the earth
than the one he got on his flight so i
thought that was pretty cool too
just to have been that prepared to know
every single thing that could go wrong
to be ready for anything
so that by the time you got up there it
was just like your your instinct as to
what to do and how to do it
yeah how did you yourself hold up doing
uh the centrifuge
i didn't have to do the centrifuge thank
god none of us did a centrifuge but
some of us had to do the uh i wouldn't
hold up well i don't think
i went to canada's wonderland a couple
of years ago and went on something very
spinny
and that didn't go well so i don't think
i'd do well in the centrifuge but the um
the mastiff which you can see in the
trailer and
uh it's a big part of our show which is
the chair that goes pitch yawn
roll it goes all three directions at
once a couple of us had to do that i
luckily
didn't have to do it i i was excited at
the possibility of doing it but then
after seeing two of the actors and what
they look like after they've been in it
for six hours i was
very happy to have to have missed out on
that particular experience
uh leonardo dicaprio is a producer on
this
uh was he very hands-on
uh i i we never had him on set because
he's an incredibly busy guy
obviously um but he what he is hands on
is in building the team that was
responsible for the show so he is he's
i think incredibly involved with
everything that his company does but
most specifically his producing partner
jennifer davison who's worked with him
for over a decade
um and they're very very close and
simpatico
uh she was really running the show and
in charge of things and i think
constantly running things by him and
making sure that
he knew the direction of the show and
was involved in reading scripts so
um i don't i think he was very involved
from as
close as he could be considering what
his schedule was like but his
producing partner jennifer was really
the uh heading things up and making sure
that everything ran on time and keeping
us on track
yeah given your your natural interest in
all this do you think that you would
sign up for space travel like
spacex is allowing regular people to go
is that for you 100
i would do it tomorrow if it weren't if
it if it weren't as expensive as it was
i would uh i would be doing it tomorrow
i i it's a bucket list thing for sure i
hope at some point in my life i get a
chance to
even just get up into a suborbital
situation to see the curvature of the
earth to just get that close to
to the darkness of space would be um
certainly top of my bucket list
what do you think the future holds for
space travel it's something that
everyone
imagines and and talks about right but
you know when you're
like when your daughter is your age
do you imagine that it'll be kind of a
regular thing that people will be able
to do
it's so hard to imagine exactly what's
going to become of it because
so much money is involved i think what
elon musk is doing with spacex and what
bezos is doing with his company you know
that's going to be what it takes is
these
um just absurdly obscenely wealthy
people who have
big imaginations and want to accomplish
something great
in this field um i think the
privatization of space which you know
i'm not a professional on this so i'm
sure there's all sorts of pitfalls
involved that i don't even fully
understand but it does seem to be
um getting us back on track in terms of
having more launches and technology
moving
quicker being able to recycle the
the uh the rockets is a big deal so you
know it seems
like elon is is dedicated to be getting
to mars
pretty quickly um and that seems to be
like the next goal in terms of
at the very least human space flight so
i think getting back to the moon and
then from the moon getting to mars seems
like the next steps
yeah do you finally have a uh a favorite
insight
of john glenn's from his experiences and
everything that he's that he's talked
about in
the intervening years since you know
what you're playing him as
that's a great question god there are so
many um
things that i learned i i kind of
defaulted the same one usually which is
something i think he said at the mercury
seven press conference and something he
repeated often throughout his life which
was something his mother taught him
which was that he believed that every
human being on earth was given a
particular set of skills they're born
with some
set of skills to which they are uniquely
qualified to
change the world or do something great
or help humanity or their community
and our job as human beings is to sort
of get out of our own way and figure out
what those skills are
and work as hard as possible to make
sure that we make the most of them
i thought that was i thought that was
beautiful and really well put when he
said that
and it certainly left a lasting effect
on me even in the months after we
wrapped i felt like
that's a way to live you know who knows
what your skill is who knows what you
were put here to do but you were put
here to do something
and it's sort of your responsibility to
figure out what that is and then just
work as hard as possible to accomplish
it
you